why do modern women love bad boys
I can't answer that one
I can answer from my perspective I feel
like
like we like bad boys because we feel
like we want to feel protected and
but I mean but what makes you feel like
a good guy can't protect you no it's not
that it's not that they can't it's just
I haven't seen that they can whereas
with like bad boys you kind of like
know what they're on to like kind of so
so sorry carry on but I want to ask you
something so do you feel it's a man's
job to protect you always yeah that's
cool no that's cool well I do my dad
protects me so I feel like when my man
should do it yeah that's cool that's
what I feel that's that's that's what we
prescribe to but there seems to be
something that goes on when we talk when
we speak like this they seems to be
different narrative that gets pushed
about how we speak about wanting to
protect women and and be there so when I
heard you say
protect that's one of the things that we
always talk about so I just picked up on
it carry on
yeah that's only that's why I would
rather
yeah
most of your friends like the nice guys
or the Bad Boys
um most of my friends
they're like bad boys as well what about
what about each other what are what are
each other's types
I just don't want somebody to make me
feel like I got a back us up and you
ain't doing nothing
you know what I'm saying no no okay I
don't want to feel like I'm in a
situation where
um a man is being disrespectful maybe I
mean maybe I'm out with my with my
fiance and we're out to dinner and maybe
somebody's been really disrespectful on
the table
um next to us I don't want to feel like
I'm going back and forth with this
person and you're just sitting there
watching us go back and forth I don't
want to feel like I'm not protected that
way so so you do like the bad boys a
little bit no it doesn't necessarily
have to be bad it just has to be
he knows how to make me feel safe it
doesn't have to be bad though okay
that's cap I'm both of their friends and
they both like back
I don't like the guy is he a bad boy is
he a bad boy you know who I'm talking
about is he a bad boy is he got time to
be a bad boy no seriously no he might
not be a bad boy now previously man man
that other men better than women do let
him talk I'm telling you like deadline
they both like bad boys what you told me
she's lying she likes Bad Boys
do you know what is it's not that she's
lying guys yeah it's
she believes that that's not what she
likes but it is what she likes
Pearl you know what I found interesting
no I don't think she does I feel like
deep down like we know we just don't
like to admit it yeah so she believes
that she doesn't like them but she does
and so and so then later when we get
bamboozled we're like oh no he's cheated
I can't believe it and it's like come on
one more time for these guys if they
told me they're seeing someone I can
just assess the situation and know
what's gonna happen but obviously I
can't say because then I'm just being
negative so what about my situation now
I told you about that already tell us
I don't want to answer it on camera
because obviously he might be watching
right now and I don't want to you know
be ready said enough stuff
you know what I've really got the gist
of it you know what you know I find it
interesting yeah you know I find it
interesting you both mentioned talked
about being protected but then when we
spoke about you going to certain places
and putting yourself in certain dangers
about putting you wasn't worried about
being protected then so uh
I don't go clubbing Festival okay I go
out for drinks yes and I go like places
with my friends but for instance if my
man didn't want like I go out because I
work
Sunday to Thursday yeah and I'm stuck in
a house from Sunday to Thursday can't
leave so on the weekend I like to go out
and let my hair down but if I had a
partner and he didn't want me to go out
with my friends I'd go out with him like
yeah okay so we're gonna we're gonna
move that yeah but the reason why I say
it is because you spoke about protection
I don't want to be out in a restaurant
and a man says something and he can't
handle it and that's perfectly fine but
now you what now you listen now you're
now you're starting to think how men
think I don't want my girl to be out in
a club or something and something
happens and I'm not there to protect her
so see a lot of things that men think
about we mitigate and we see dangers a
lot of dangers you may not see and it's
the part of of you know loving loving
loving your family loving your girl have
sisters and and I've had relationships
where your girl's gonna go outside and
then something's gonna happen and you
know now you get the call and upset girl
now you have to come outside you might
be giving your bridge on a call now he
has to come outside now so when we step
outside now two things can happen
um well more than two things can happen
but now I'm putting my safety at
Jeopardy because I'm about to go into
scenario which I don't know because
something could have happened happened
to you and on top of that I'm putting my
potentially putting my freedom on the
line as well so these are two scenarios
that have happened all because
potentially you went into somewhere
where you didn't have to go and that's
not stopping you from going out it's
just when we say when I'm when your man
asks you certain things this is these
are the things that we think of so you
always ready you likened it to being at
a restaurant and um my man's there to
protect me in case someone disrespects
me but if your man's not there this is
how we think what if someone disrespects
her then so I just want you to think
about that a little bit just after that
point sorry as well is that you have the
expectation for the man to protect you
that's got to be a man that you listen
to Because Why is a guy gonna be willing
to do all of these things to protect
someone that when he says something she
won't even listen to him you know what I
mean it's like having your cake and
eating it
and the guy is willing to do a lot more
for a girl that he knows will listen to
him when he says sign no facts about
anything like if you like like
there's so much power and femininity
like you know how mad it is like you
women sometimes don't understand how
much power that you have like just by
listening and just by actually just
saying you know actually I agree oh
you're like oh she listens to me oh
she's a winner let me go and do
something nice for her just something as
simple as that
but instead you want to back you want to
battle and we're like oh not actually
gonna go cheat on her not joking
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats
um guys make sure you like the video the
like is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so make sure you like the video also
guys we are trying to get to
500 000 subscribers which is not so I
mean we've been doing the show what like
six seven months like we're almost to
500k come on come on
um also sorry guys my laptop's being
weird
um also don't forget to leave a comment
on the stream and let me know what
topics you'd like us to see next week
and a reminder that the top um the top
Super chat today gets to have something
on the board tomorrow
um I think we're gonna do it a little
further back so you can see it better
but we'll have your username and then
whatever you want as um the title
so um let's go um see sir deck
um it's not that she's lying it's not
that she's lying because she believes
the it's not that she's lying it's
because she believes the lie your honor
the prosecution rests
um leather skirt has never heard these
views proof of feminism programming the
media saturate saturated
saturated with it brainwashing the
masses this is why shows like this are
so important and get so much push back
zentian Simpson males who lack a spine
character and conviction to actually go
after the women they want while allowing
a friend to come over to their mother's
house I smell thrilledness on the sofa I
see him as an up-and-coming Will Smith
or Derek Jacks
Professor Trill you're willing to give
up a man that wants you for a man that
doesn't want you make it make sense as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible